[Music]
delighted to meet you thank you doing
this today our point of contact was our
mutual friend Jeff Moore denier who has
been singing your praises for a long
time yeah so great and I texted him the
other day and I was like what should I
talk to her about that you know I'm not
gonna find on Google and he was like
well she's she has this you know very
calming voice and she's very present but
don't be mistaken because she's a tiger
very fierce you know you don't you know
you've achieved a lot like I mean first
of all you're this amazing you know
award-winning chef with all these
accolades and then you get long listed
for a National Book Award for your book
it's like it's not fair you're both
things like you could be a great chef
you could be a great writer but to do
both that's quite something so
congratulations I'm in shock stone yeah
because that was a recent I was pretty
recently announced right yeah September
now all that stuff work I I don't know
honestly I it was a shock to me because
I woke up that morning and I had like 25
text messages and a lot of emails and
you know Twitter notifications and all
that stuff with you know people saying
congratulations and I was like what
happened and then and then you know I
think it was actually Jeff who explained
it to me he's like you got the National
Book Award long list and then I had to
look all of that up you know I mean I
knew that it was out there but I didn't
know you know I I went to writing school
a long time ago and I remember that
there's all these things that you know
you can get awarded for books but I was
never thinking about that while writing
the book you know I thought if it sells
if it makes like a you know best list or
best sellers list that would be
more than I could hope for and so that
coming was just like yeah a huge
surprise in something I wasn't even
thinking of yeah what do you make of all
of it I mean it made me feel really good
about the book because the night before
I was writing my second book which I'm
working on with my publisher which is
about foraging but still in a narrative
style and I was you know looking at some
references for my book sales and it was
doing kind of poorly and I was sitting
there thinking I don't even know if you
know like staying up after work till
2:00 in the morning is even worth it you
know writing this book and kind of
sweating about it and I'm and you know
being in self-doubt and then the next
morning that the long list out I didn't
and you know and I was like oh you know
that felt really really good
yeah the first food-oriented book since
Julia Child in 1980 yeah
which also again yeah I was just like
but yeah I didn't understand how that
works because the there's been so many
good food writers and authors and so
many books that have come out in food
and about food and memoirs and how you
know mine made it and not some of the
others that have been there is beyond me
and I'm assuming all publishers send
their books to the National Book Award
to the foundation you know when they
come out in whichever John rrah
whether it's fiction nonfiction etc so
yeah it's pretty cool it was very cool I
don't think it's fair to characterize it
as just a food book it really I mean
it's about food of course but you know
it's a coming-of-age book it's a it's a
coming-out story it's an addiction
recovery story I mean you know as
somebody who
you know myself I've been in recovery
for a long time and I love a good you
know addiction yarn there's plenty of
them out there but your voice is so
specific and to me it felt very unique
in that regard as somebody who's read a
lot of these kinds of stories and just
beautifully done and it was interesting
how your tone shifted depending upon
what period of your life you were
talking about it was as if you were
writing it in the voice of that person
at that time and it involves as you
progress through your life yeah I mean
there's some things that I while I was
writing the book you know I was doing on
a little bit on purpose like that
that was one of them I was trying to
inhabit me at the time you know and some
of the almost synesthesia of the
narrative was also you know purposefully
done I like to read books that don't
follow linear timelines and even if I'm
telling stories which you've probably
already noticed since I've been here is
like I stopped an idea go back and then
come back to it and you know continue
going because I just don't think
linearly I guess I don't know I go all
over the place yeah it's very it's it's
snippets of memory that are woven
together in this tapestry and I think
synesthesia is a perfect adjective for
it I mean it's very rooted in the
sensory and memory and you know the
smells kind of come alive with the pages
especially you know in the food aspects
of the story and telling it you know in
the present state of what you recollect
as opposed to through the rearview
mirror with perspective mm-hmm yeah um
and I I had actually talked to my
publisher quite a bit about a lot of the
storytelling process and what I was
doing and you know he just kept
encouraging me to to go with it and
I said I don't think I can tell this
story if I don't just like drop the
reader right into the moment and
continue on from there and with it
jumping around I said if I go in a
linear fashion to me the way it just
comes out is this really boring essay
telling and I just don't want to do that
and at first he had a little bit of
concerned but then he was like just you
know do whatever I think that was the
cool thing about working with somebody
who was or is a small publisher in an
indie publisher because you know he was
just like let's you know let's do it I
think your your honesty is remarkable
and it's not that common to find a
writer who just like spills it all out
even some of the passages he's like
actually this is too much information
you can't say this week we got to cut
this thing out you know so I think that
he knew that that was going to be really
good for readers and really be able to
help you know people be able to to
relate to the book and really become
engaged yeah I mean you you it seems
like you almost go out of out of your
way to not overly romanticize any of it
like you're you're you're making a clear
point of the fact that you know there is
a there is a lens on which you could
look at your story and say oh look look
you know look where she came from and
look at all she's accomplished and isn't
this amazing and sort of make it more
glamorous than it actually was in your
experience and you're just sort of very
plainly showing the truth of it without
sugar coating it in any way yeah and I
think that you know maybe that's just me
being a little bit different as a chef
because I feel like that is what I do
and that's what I love to do and it's an
expression of myself and I love cooking
and
you know but it's really more than that
because I love the storytelling of the
cooking like gathering our ingredients
and growing things and that's a big part
of where we're going with our property
in the Upper Peninsula in Michigan is to
make it just feel a little bit more
holistic because if this is going to be
my career like I can't continue to do it
how I do it at the restaurant you know
and I'm talking like three four or five
years down the line and I just want to
feel I guess better about it and I think
that a lot of people look at like chefs
and and my industry as being kind of
glamorous but it doesn't feel like that
at least not for me not on a daily basis
so it was one of the things I struggled
with actually and the last part of the
book talking about my career because I
didn't want to sound ungrateful because
I I am and I've accomplished a lot but
like there's very little glamour to it
on a daily basis you know like I feel
more also like I wake up to beat my head
against the wall every morning right
before I go to work right you know so
that glamour I think you know is people
always when I meet them they're like oh
what do you do you know if they say what
do you do I just say I'm a cook at a
restaurant like because I want to talk
about if you say your chef will be like
oh you're a chef and are you own your
own restaurant that must be amazing and
I'm just thinking about like all the
nights you know the dishwasher called in
because they're in jail or my staff was
like [ __ ] you I'm leaving or somebody
still checks or you know just like all
those all those like things that happen
at work on a daily basis that are so
unglamorous and quite terrible when you
when it comes to managing others that
you know that yeah that's what like is
the first thing that that comes to mind
and then I have to remind myself
I'm talking to them like I just need to
talk about how I love cooking you know
because but yeah if I can avoid the
situation altogether like when I first
met my wife's family a lot of them knew
I had a restaurant and I just was like
having such a hard time because
everybody wanted to talk about how cool
it was and you know I was like just
struggling to be like yeah it's kind of
an insular you know perhaps somewhat
introverted person contemplatively
because the roots of your passion are
found in the woods by yourself foraging
for these foods and you know a very kind
of solo affair and this love of you know
combining flavors to create interesting
you know interesting recipes etc but
then that means that you open a
restaurant you're managing all these
people and you're looking at
spreadsheets and you're dealing with
human resources and payroll and all the
like that has nothing to do with what
got you into it in the first place yeah
and I think I was just really naive when
I was going into it not realizing that
with a small business like you know and
the business models set up to be really
small that that I think most chefs go
into it thinking like I'm just gonna
cook this beautiful food and not really
thinking about takes care of itself
yeah and that was so not the case
because I am the human resources and you
know the payroll person in all those
other things I do have somebody helping
me now but sometimes in the past like
you know everybody comes and goes in so
it's um it's it's complicated but I do
tell people that like if you know I
could people often say like off you
could go back and talk to your younger
self what would you say and I would say
like don't open a restaurant and
but then I then the other part of that
is my younger self that I would be
talking to would still do it
like that's where I was at that time
there was nobody even my future self
would have been able to tell me to not
do it and I would have listened or like
I wouldn't have listened I was listening
to your conversation with David Chang on
his podcast and that was something that
you guys explored like the mental health
aspect of what it means to on a daily
basis to actually do like what you guys
do and the toll that it takes and he
kind of closes the whole thing by saying
like you know this industry is the worst
like I love it it's the best you know
it's that tension yeah and I see that
that kind there you know there is this
duality that infuses your book and your
work and your ethos and and even you
know how you parse your tattoos on your
arms this this you know dichotomy of
light and dark that kind of you leverage
to you know be the Creator that you are
yeah and I I think that some of that is
like you know when you're talking about
mental health and and people in the
industry particularly well I think
there's a lot of creative industries
which this is a common theme but you
know it's like the chicken or the egg
like it's the work make us crazy are we
already crazy for me it's definitely
that I was already a little bit of a
nutjob so that works that you know it
makes sense that I'm doing what I do you
know and it's almost like you know
talking about addiction is like I'm
addicted to those actual Heights and
lows you know and maybe when I get
somewhere else a little bit more like
older and wiser like I can look back and
be like well that's what was happening
like I'm you know beating my head
against the wall but I was addicted to
like that
dropping pain from beating my head
against the wall you know like that's
that's yeah I guess yeah so I'm just
addicted to those highs and lows
probably still you and me both yeah well
there's no shortage of
addicts and alcoholics and people in
recovery in your in your graves you know
it's definitely it definitely magnetizes
people that are attracted to those
polarities mm-hmm so I'm sure you yeah
like you said like the dishwashers in
jail yeah I mean maybe I'm in jail I can
say that because it's happened to us
about three different times where you
know the the dishwashers roommate or
sister or cousin or somebody has called
and said you know they can't come in or
we've called them looking for them and
you know they said oh they're there in
jail you know but in a couple days
they'll be out and you know they can
come back and it's like they never show
it usually we're desperate enough to be
like alright we'll see them in a couple
days and then they still don't show up
so but right now at Elizabeth well for
the past like six years probably aside
from you know the other jobs they do
like teaching the staff in creating the
menus and all that like while I'm at
work during service my primary job has
been doing the dishes that doesn't seem
right but see that's another thing too
that I could go on and on about at work
but when other people do them it kind of
drives me crazy because I'm like no it
should be cleaner and more organized and
you're going to slow let me just do it
yeah but this is the control freak
alcoholic in you yeah yeah it is even
when like I am doing the dishes and
somebody comes over to help me one of my
staff members I'm like hey like you're a
mime in the song you know huh
back off yeah it's my station that's not
gonna work yeah but this is the trip
right so how do you think about the
relationship like your the relationship
creatively between cooking and writing
like are the they're both you know
equally creative and you're you excel in
both like do those feed off each other
or yeah I think of them as different
disciplines or are they all wanting the
same
it's definitely the same for me because
when I decided to wear and I might have
talked about this in the book but when I
was 28 years old I thought all right
like I'm either going to go back to
school for writing and get my MFA and
you know maybe try to teach and take
that route or I'm just gonna open a
restaurant which is something else that
I always wanted to do and so I decided
to open a restaurant and so I had to you
know figure out how to do that by
creating a name and and doing it a
little bit unconventionally because I
hadn't gone to cooking school and I
hadn't worked my way up through the
restaurants like some of the other chefs
had was you know working for Charlie
Trotter or this person or that person
and but I was you know thinking about
these two options and I was talking to a
lot of friends about it who knew that I
had gone to school for writing and that
I was actually really active it with it
even while I was still working in
restaurants I was always working on a
book or you know working on a collection
of poetry or whatever it was and I spent
a lot of time doing that and so they
would ask like well what about your
writing you know you're gonna do this
restaurant thing how are you gonna do
writing in after I was already pretty
immersed in it maybe like a year in and
really focusing on getting myself
up-to-date with kitchen work
I felt like creating menus was equally
as it fed that creative energy just as
equally as writing to it like I could
get lost in the creation of a menu and
thinking about it in different
presentations and how I want it to look
or how I want it to I don't know just
taste and what that means are where I
could find it and how it could be a
representation of you know time and
place or you know a memory and so that
yeah that was equally there
and so then now like actually doing both
is really fulfilling and and somehow I
you know was able to divide my time to
be able to you know not only work in the
restaurant and do all that stuff but
then also right but it was still coming
from the same creative energy yeah well
you you had a unique path in your kind
of ascension as a chef like yes you
didn't go to culinary school you didn't
you know sort of apprentice under these
well-known chefs but you put your time
in a ton of restaurants in this goes
back all the way to you being you know
the youngest child like foraging with
your family and so let's let's start at
the beginning a little bit and talk a
little bit about that and I think what
comes across so so beautifully in the
book is again back to this duality or
this tension like this sense from a very
early age like this isn't really my home
and I need to get away from here in
order to find myself and and connect
with my identity but also a real
reverence and respect and appreciation
and love for the way in which you were
brought up and taught you this way of
living that infuses your food mm-hmm
yeah I was um I I don't know I feel like
I got really really lucky to have had
the the family that I did and grow up
where I did I mean that even um my
family members who our extended family
members feel the same way about the
farmhouse that I grew up in you know and
have such like cherished memories from
that time one of my cousins is pretty
close in age to me and she basically
grew up there with me and um you know
she just is like in love with it too you
know so I was really lucky to have that
and that was part of what I was trying
to express in the book because all my
most of my memories of that place are
somewhat centered around food you know
and that's how my family operated my dad
loved food in loved cooking and my mom
had her own like relationship with food
that was on a lot of different levels
and so they kind of provided that
atmosphere which was just kind of really
magical and special and so every single
thing we did as a family was always
centered around some kind of meal and
and it was always really good to you
know and sometimes it was something that
was just simple from the garden or
sometimes it was you know really complex
like roasting whole animals and you know
what whatever it was but I was through
the book trying to you know show that
like my ascension into the career that I
had was definitely I pretty much you
know without cooking school didn't
really need it because like I got all
the training I needed throughout my life
you know which started really early like
I don't know a lot of four-year-olds who
sit and hold the intestines as you know
the their dad is stuffing the sausage or
whatever you know so so that was you
know I think just like extremely special
especially you know when I look back at
it because mmm as as a kid I might not
have always felt like that you know
maybe when I was 8 or 9 or 10 like I was
really jealous of my friends who lived
in neighborhoods and could ride their
bikes on the street and do all those
sorts of things but you know there was
plenty of what I had that was also just
incomparable like you know no one else
had that right so basically this sort of
Gothic pastoral you know landscape and
Indiana couple hours outside of Chicago
farmland there's this pull this a lure
of the forest and you kind of invert the
fairy tale you know kind of aspects of
what it means to be a child wandering
around in the forest and I think the
passage it really encapsulate s-- the
whole book in your story and what spoke
to me you know very powerfully was the
story of you I think you're five at the
time and you're going out into the
forest with your dad to forage for for
chanterelles and he teaches you how to
shoot a gun and there's a sketchy uncle
that's involved and a tornado that
threatens your life and and it all
culminates with you basically cooking
what you foraged with your family and it
kind of ends nicely but it it has I mean
not in and of itself is almost like a
fable and you kind of close that by
saying I escaped fate and dismembered
that I was a chef or something along
those lines but I think you could easily
also say like you didn't escape fate
like this is you connecting with your
like this is a faded thing like this is
bred into you from as early as you can
remember that this was gonna be your
pack right that's actually that's a lot
of what I'm exploring in my new book
which is going to be about foraging and
very much in in a similar narrative
style and where I'm kind of going with
that is you know with kind of playing
along the lines of inherited trauma and
I'm still trying to research a bit of it
and learn more about how you know our
ancestors experience get burned into our
DNA and that a lot of like the trauma
perhaps does but also I'm thinking about
like what about you know the other
things that are perhaps just like
predetermined in that kind of way
because my my dad's grandmother so my
great-grandmother actually in Poland
she had an inn you know and she
was a chef and then she came here she
married a a wrestler from the circus
which is wild Wow they they came to the
United States and then in Gary Indiana
where they ended up living they had a
hamburger shop and she had a really
popular hamburger shop and then
eventually my my my debt her daughter
took over
you know Jenny's cafe which my mom was
the chef at and and things like that so
I mean that's a that's a long line of
you know people in the food industry and
people connected to food and I thought
that was just I I didn't know that about
my great-grandmother until I was asking
my dad a lot of questions because he's
got a lot of stories about our family
history and he just recently told me
about that because I had known that she
had a burger shop in Gary Indiana but I
hadn't known about her life before that
and then I was asking him and he said
that yeah she had an inn and I was
really shocked and you know I was like
well isn't that you know apropos
considering like we've just opened in it
in as well you know yeah well you drop
these hints in the book I mean there's
sort of that just the detritus of the
restaurant you know backed away in the
house and you tell the story of your mom
quitting and you know working there so
yeah this is part of the fabric of who
you are on dating way back which is
super interesting yeah yes uh you know
maybe that all has has been fate I just
in the book was describing sliding it is
you know as perhaps I was destined to be
a transgender truck driving carnie
because from such an early age I was in
love with the fair and I mean obsessed
with it and maybe that was the whole
grandfather being a wrestler in the
circus I don't know but I was also very
you know obsessed with becoming a boy
and then from early age to like I was
fascinated with semi-truck
then wanted to tell like every time I
was on my bike I was pretending I was
and driving around the neighbor's
driveway which was paved because ours
was gravel I was you know pretending I
was in my semi so I still love road
trips but yeah but yeah so I don't know
just maybe that's a future job that rest
[Laughter]
let's talk about that I mean the the
coming of age the coming out aspect of
the story I mean infused throughout this
is this you know sense of displacement
this idea like I'm suppose you know I
I'm I'm a boy you're sort of being
affirmed as a boy by your dad and this
grappling that you do with identity
dates back also as far as you can
remember yeah I mean that it dates back
before I think I can could even talk
because and again I don't know if I put
this in the book I can't remember but
one of my clearest earliest memories is
of sitting on the floor with my cousin
who I said had grown up with me and we
were not even walking age and she was on
my left and they somebody whoever was
taking the picture gave us Minnie and
Mickey dolls to hold and they gave me
the Minnie and her the Mickey and I took
the Mickey and threw her the Minnie
because for some reason and my kid head
was like I'm the boy without even I
don't even think I had the words for it
it was just like I want that doll not
the one with the pink bow and so yeah I
mean that that was definitely predating
being able to like verbalize any of that
so you know I don't know if that goes to
being born gay or born in a different
you know gender just like the the
affirmation of
gender fluidity you know and people
saying it's not as binary as you know it
has to be and you know there's not a
part of me today that is like I'm a boy
although I do very much feel like you
know and this is a little bit
stereotyping but how women are like
sometimes conditioned or just feel
naturally competitive with other women I
don't feel that at all
but I feel competitive with men mm-hmm
you know and I don't know what that is
maybe because like I have a little bit
of that masculinity or testosterone
that's like know that that's my
competition and I gotta be better than
them or maybe it was always in my life
you know people saying but you're not a
boy but you're not a boy and then I was
like but I'm gonna do boy thinks you
know I'm gonna show you I can you know
be better than them or whatever it was I
don't I don't know there's just there's
a lot to explore there but yeah so that
my dad did always say that like he'd be
like yeah you're a little boy and I
don't know if like that was just him
teasing or him actually thinking that I
was going to be gay someday and like
allowing that process to already form
actually he probably didn't think that
but he would because he was quite like
sexist he is quite sexist in homophobic
not now but like he would say derogatory
things when I was younger about you know
gay people or whatever and so none of
that stopped me from feeling the way
that I did or feeling afraid of you know
becoming gay but I don't know I don't
know what that was necessarily or what
his standpoint was but my mom said that
at a Earl like when I was pretty young
her and my dad had talked about the fact
that you know I might turn out gay
someday or somehow different because of
my adamancy about like I want to wear
boy things and I want to
like a boy and all this stuff and she
said that they like reconciled with that
really early on and just kind of let me
be me right and how are they how are
they now with everything they're fine
I mean my dad still worries that you
know on and I don't have a man around to
take care of things you know he's like
last time he was up he he brought his
paper towel in toilet paper like we're
not going to have any and like you know
keeps bringing guns and stuff that's
where he Brady
yeah so but yeah he's he's very
convinced that without you know some
kind of male supervision that we might
just like wither and die and but yeah my
mom is like Vince you know like if she's
coming she's like very happy about you
know she's she's extremely proud I mean
he he is too but in his own special way
right I thought it was really intriguing
how you begin to explore this non-binary
world through the discovery of people
like Boy George and really lacks who are
like icons of you know that notion that
it's it need not be one or the other so
talk a little bit about how that kind of
impacted how you reflected on yourself
yeah I that was I mean so early that I
you know saw Boy George on the
television and was like wow just somehow
I immediately identified with that even
though you know and just fascinated and
sort of what is this but also
understanding it completely at the same
time and I
think just being you know maybe it was a
feeling of feeling not alone to be able
to see a man you know looking so
beautiful and dressed like a woman you
know like kind of with makeup and long
hair and all of that and then also to
see Annie Lennox
and almost feel like if I could think
about it feel like I shouldn't be
watching this because I'm having
feelings you know like even as a kid
like not like sexual feelings or
anything like that but almost feeling
embarrassed in and I don't think I know
anything about her sexuality at all but
seeing a woman who was very ambiguous
and you know with short hair and wearing
a suit and just thinking like that's me
too
you know so being able to see both of
them and feeling like completely
connected but even her more so and yeah
like I said like kind of feeling
embarrassed like I'm supposed to look
away because if anybody sees how
enthralled I am with this then I'm gonna
be found out yeah that's - yeah but but
it had to be empowering to see people
like that who are so strong and
unapologetic about who they are right
like they're standing in their strength
in a very in a very profound way right
where they're like this is who I am and
there's a boldness to that I think is
you know it's it's hard to look away
yeah and that was that that was like the
only reference I had for anything like
that when I was young I think at some
some points like later on in life maybe
when I was in you know my my early teens
like some of my sisters my my sister
Nina would you know like if there was
something that was a little bit gay and
not that much was coming out on TV but
it was starting to she would you know
say oh did you see this or
you watched this or you know like one of
my sisters gave me I was just talking
about this the other day
my oldest sister Elizabeth gave me that
she was always giving me books to read
because she was like she I don't know
she probably read like 25 books a year
she was very well-read and she yeah she
liked all different genres and she gave
me the interview with a vampire
they Anne Rice and I really that
actually was a moment when I came out to
myself through reading that book was
like I'm gay because there's a lot of
the homoeroticism and I think they even
might be partners at one point and and I
can't remember the book completely but
lists that and yeah but they ordered
dummy now I can't remember but I know
that they become involved at certain
points and my you know I'm like okay I
know that I feel this way too but not
about men but about women and just
reading about that was like oh yeah I'm
I am that I am gay like this is what I
am and so I was probably maybe like 14
or 15 even though I had some moments
before then where you know I would kind
of come out to to myself and say yeah
you know this is what it is but then try
to push it away but that was one really
affirming moment the other was I was in
are in the movie theater with my mom and
one of my good friends and we are
watching Don Juan DeMarco with Johnny
Depp and I think that's who was in it
and she kept fawning over Johnny Depp
like aw you're so cute he's so cute and
I was like okay that the woman in the
show is really what Hauser's you know
and so it was at that moment to those
were one of the moments I was like
that's straight and I am not that you
know yeah so but I don't know how I got
on that
epic anyways I think just don't you know
George yeah yeah boy it's starting
George but just this process of
self-discovery unfolding and you know
the way that you recount it makes me
think I wonder what it's like now I mean
this is pre-internet the priest all have
tons of problems but there is a
mainstreaming to this that you know
didn't exist at that time
yeah Anna and I talk about that a lot
because we talk about how how children
now you know who are able to transition
because they feel one as a separate
gender and how it's actually you know
the earlier they start some of the
hormones and things the better for their
transition later in life and you know
she says I wonder if you know you were
born now like how that would have
impacted you and would you had changed
like would I be a guy sitting there you
know and it's like wow that I mean
that's a really incredible question
because I know for me like I'm very
happy you know being a woman and
inhabiting a woman's body no matter what
you know I may feel inside but I don't
feel like completely the opposite sex
either you know and so I'm glad that
that wasn't part of my experience but
you know it's really interesting to
think about because yeah I probably
would have you know given the choice
been like yeah let's do it
right to train a little penis yeah it's
it's it's complicated because on the one
hand it allows people to accept
themselves and be accepted for you know
wanting that and to get support for that
but also if it's if it's at a point
where they're not fully mature are they
really in a place to make that decision
that has an impact on the rest of their
life right like will they change will
they will they you know develop a
different perspective yeah that's why I
I feel like it's it's interesting to
think about but something I can't speak
to you know because like
I can never say what what would happen
and my experience has been that I'm I'm
fine but that doesn't mean that other
children are necessarily ever going to
be fine with staying in that same gender
you know but it's it's yeah it's really
just a mind it's like so it's yeah it's
just it's very easy to mess with your
mind thinking about that thing and I
mean we've even talked about it like
what if our children you know want a
transition and I'm like I don't even
know how to think about that yeah well
you cross that bridge when you yeah well
let's talk about that drugs and alcohol
so where does this start yeah go for it
when does that start to creep in and
Raritan well from an early age I had
seen a lot of alcoholism in my family
whether it was big like my uncle Georgie
who was very scary and very aggressive
as as an alcoholic and you know would
come over to the house with guns and
shoot him and you know like at the house
or whatever like so knowing that that's
one form that alcoholism takes in
another form as you know seeing my
sister stumble around sort of dead drunk
and be in trouble and or going up I
remember my mom I was small enough that
my mom was carrying me and we got to the
top of our stairs and looking into my
sister's room and knowing that she was
in trouble maybe it was the feeling that
I had from my mom but knowing my sister
was in trouble and her passed out in the
bed with you know puke all over her bed
sheets and stuff because she had been
vomiting in the night and so there and
then there was the times where it was
like oh these adults are getting louder
and they're funnier and they're being
goofy but it's not scary
so that being said though I think that
that's also part of like it kind of
explains like I was saying earlier the
chicken with the egg with you know and
also being addicted to some of that head
banging anxiety or whatever it is
because as a child even though that
could all be really scary like I still
thought was very intrigued by like what
alcohol could do like I was like this
thing's very bad but I definitely want
it and so then when I started drinking I
mean I had like a couple times where I
had sips of beer you know my dad would
give me mogen David shots when I would
cough at night and you know but I had
never experienced what actual drunk
could feel like but the first time I did
experience that my brain was definitely
not wired to be like okay you've had
enough now you should stop I think some
normal people they go through that
feeling where they're like oh I'm
feeling good like all right I probably
don't need any more but that's not what
happens to my my brain or my body it's
like just it needs as much as possible
and from the get-go yeah and so when I
was the first time I drank that was my
experience with it and I know you know
addiction and and alcoholism can
manifest in different ways within people
whereas they used to maybe be able to
control their their alcohol intake and
then some days something happens where
it just switches and they can't anymore
or it might be external or internal
event but for me it was right from the
beginning so you know going also back to
like that inherited trauma or DNA maybe
you know that was definitely if it's a
gene that gets passed along I definitely
got that yeah gene you know because
right from the start but also it you
know it allowed me to feel comfortable
in a body that I never really felt
comfortable in and also
a mind which my you know my head was
always somewhere else and always
imagining you know some other time in
life and it allowed me to you know feel
normal because I was always interpreted
and always shy and always awkward and as
a kid that didn't always play out the
best way like why are you so shy why are
you so quiet you know when people then
would turn the light on my awkwardness
then I felt more awkward you know and
wanted to like shut down even more and
so then shutting down even more would
create more of an issue and to where
like when my family would have functions
if certain people were coming over I
would go and hide in my closet until
they were gone like hide the entire time
because they were somebody who expected
me to be like a child like who should
play and talk to them and and and it
scared me and I didn't want to be like
focused on you know which is all just
crazy too because when you think about
my career it's all about the focus so
it's it's just it's a very
multi-dimensional but yeah what were we
talking about just talking about the
beginning of alcoholism and I thought
that I think what you're saying gets
glossed over and doesn't get enough
attention which is that it works like
there's it yes there's a part of this I
mean what you just shared it could be
you know my story is very different from
yours but like I completely relate to
everything that you just said like and I
felt my own experience through the lens
of your own in that it brings you out of
your shell it makes you feel normal and
like you can talk to another human being
that you're comfortable in your own skin
and it's almost like oh this is how
everybody else feels all the time like I
want to feel like this all the time to
get that yeah you know yeah and it isn't
like well one day you know one day
it's fine in the next day it's a problem
this plays out over a very long period
of time like it works until it stops
working right but that's not a binary
thing either this is a scale and for me
it worked for a long time and I think it
worked for a long time for you like I
look at the way that I interact with
people and I learned certain social
skills as a result of drinking and using
that I don't know how I would have
learned otherwise maybe I would have
just locked myself in my room
it is not felt and and I would imagine
that you know despite the fact that you
insist on washing the dishes at your own
restaurant you do have to manage people
and you have to interact with them and
in very close quarters right and so some
of those skills come out through the
social lubricant
you know initially it teaches you how to
do these kinds of things yeah but I
honestly for me in recovery I had to
relearn all of that and now where I
learn it is is actually through the
program of Alcoholics Anonymous like
that's that's what worked for me because
like I learned there how to share with
people and be able to you know by I
don't know for you if your story if
you're familiar with it but there's
something called the fifth step where
you you share like all of you know
everything you just share everything
right and it was by sharing with another
human being on that very personal level
that I learned how to talk to other
people and kind of be able to learn how
to express myself in my emotions and
just communicate and also learning how
to talk with others like in the
restaurant and with you know being a
manager and being able to like look at
you know the things that might be
frustrating to me but also how to
address them and being mindful of my
tone and I'm not always good at it but
at least I have some kind of mechanism
and place to go back to where I've
gotten some tools in some experience
being able to
to like just go through interactions
that might be you know normal for some
but for me feel really painful
especially just sometimes just even
having a conversation with somebody and
be you know like one of the things that
has been an issue with me is just
expecting that people should know how I
feel but I'm also somebody who doesn't
really emotes so or have good
communication skills so you know how are
they gonna expect to know what to do or
to know when you know something was done
wrong if I don't you know go ahead and
have the conversation about it but then
also have the conversation in a way that
is you know not gonna hurt them and be
able to communicate what I need done
effectively you know right so that's a
lot of energy yeah well I'm no stranger
to this in fact I had a why my second
sponsor was from Chicago and I know the
recovery community in Chicago is really
really strong I know that I lots of lots
of you know people from Chicago moved
out to Los Angeles and I don't know a
few meetings out that way and I know
like what that community is all about
and I know it's really tight but yeah
you learn these tools you learn how to
own your own [ __ ] you learn how to
understand your story you learn how to
develop empathy for other human beings
and see see the world through their
perspective and all of this lends itself
to improving you know education skills
sure yeah
yeah and I said but I think that that
was a big part of um with writing the
book is that because like I learned how
to share and learn how to talk and
essentially learn how to tell the truth
like through the program it was easy for
me to just kind of like spill it all out
you know and like I said my my editor
was like well you know like I think your
honesty in this book is really unique
and and that's gonna be really good
and I wasn't even thinking about that
yeah that's the thing cuz you spent
thousands of hours in these rooms
listening to people right either most
vulnerable and honest selves and you
learn to do that for yourself and it
becomes second nature and it's always
surprising when you kind of take that
out into the rest of the world and
people are like whoa you're so honest
becomes second nature right and that's I
was explaining that to somebody to it's
like I will never feel more vulnerable
than in those moments where I had to
walk in a room full of strangers and say
that like I'm actually not well you know
and that I'm an alcoholic and that
rawness it it feels very much like you
know maybe how some people have the
dream where they're you know naked in
front of a crowd and which is sometimes
still I have that that dream too and
it's like oh my god how did I get here
why am i naked right now but yeah I
think that that that's the most
vulnerable situations I've ever been in
having to like you know go into the room
and say that I have this problem when I
had spent so much time trying to situate
the outside so it didn't look like that
you know yet I think there's a
temptation or one thing that I see in
kind of the addiction nonfiction you
know memoir space is people with super
crazy stories you know it's like like
who's got the craziest using story and I
appreciate it
the fact that yours like yeah you tell
some crazy stories but it's not like I'm
trying to you know out crazy everyone
else this is just my personal thing and
it has its own demoralizing aspects to
it and things that maybe for normal
people might seem shocking but for me
I'm like yeah this is just you know this
is like here's an alcoholic and an
addict being honest about what happened
what it was like what happened and what
it's like now mm-hmm
yeah I I actually think that there was a
part of me as I was writing the book was
thinking of
it in those terms you know because it
was separated into the three parts and
it was like yet what it was like what
happened and what it was like what it's
like now you know these things we
learned in that construct yes so there
was a lot there there's a lot to be said
for you know like that you know I think
what was making me think of this was
like talking about yeah the the social
lubricant of alcohol and how that taught
me to be a certain way but then also
like a a had to reteach me how to be a
certain way and there's a lot to be said
for that because like I don't think I I
mean I I say this definitely at least in
the acknowledgments of my book but you
know if it wasn't for that I wouldn't
have anything that I have today uh-huh
you know so how do you think about the
tradition of not sharing at the level of
press radio and film like did that
infuse how you thought about how to talk
about this in the book right it's like
it's a tricky thing right and when I for
the first like five years of the program
I didn't and I had already had my
restaurant for about three years and
what ended up happening was that I was
in a car in the car with somebody from
the press because before I had never
mentioned it at any public level like
people who were close to me knew and my
staff would know and things like that
but there I had a big book in there and
she had asked me about it and then I was
like this is off the record but you know
here's the deal and but it still made it
to the it still made it to print and
actually I had even though I was off the
record she still put it in yeah it was
still it still made it and I have to
take that back because I don't know if I
said this is off the record but I said
this is something I don't talk about and
then when it was going to print I asked
her to please take it out because I
think she might have sent me this
first but it she didn't mmm so it stayed
in there so I can't remember the exact
conversation but either way I had asked
for it not to be in there but that story
was the story that my publisher read and
came to me and said I think you have an
interesting story and I want you to
write a memoir so and a lot of that had
to do with you know obviously my
associates a memoir I have to talk about
everything and so then I talked to my
sponsor about it and said like here's
what I'm gonna do and I have this memoir
and you know this I also talked to her
about the piece that had come out in the
magazine about it and was like it's kind
of out there now and so there was a lot
of conversations about like well what
are you trying to get from this you know
and I was like honestly nothing just
trying to tell my story and so we were
talking a lot about just making sure
that it's right-sized wherever it is and
that it's not from like a platform of
like I'm so great or look at all these
accomplishments or like you know I got
sober you should do it to her you know
trying to be like a spearhead or however
you want to call it of AAA because um I
definitely don't think like you know
there's definitely moments that I even
have up to this day where it's like if
people knew that'd be pretty
embarrassing they'd be like if that's an
alcoholic and she's sober I don't want
to get sober I might as well stay drunk
you know I don't want to be the
spokesperson you know but yeah so I
I guess you know if anything whenever I
go to actually a 12-step meeting where
we do the work out of the it's my Monday
night meeting and I really love it and
we work out of the the twelve and twelve
and whenever we get to that tradition
I'm like I hope I don't have to comment
yeah
that's just kind of how I feel in the
room about it like and I know that some
people know what I do and some people
don't and I just kind of leave it that
way and I just always hope that the
comments don't come to me when we're on
that that tradition I'm not specific
well it's a it's a it's a tricky thing
I mean I've struggled with this quite a
bit because on the one hand like I
certainly don't want to hold myself out
as a parent a paragon of sobriety like I
have my struggles just like everybody
else but also when I got sober you know
12-step was like this black box that I
knew nothing about and I've often
thought like if I'd known a little bit
more about it or if somebody I respect
it had referenced it or talked about it
a little bit more openly perhaps I would
have found myself towards it a little
bit sooner and I understand the
principles behind the tradition and all
of that but there's a lot of people out
there suffering who don't know what to
do also and so it creates this kind of
confusion yeah I mean honestly there has
been a sense that one piece came out and
even things that have happened since
then that have come out and with the
book there's been a lot of people who
have reached out to me because of their
struggle so I know that it's helping in
some ways probably hopefully more than
than hurting anything but one one woman
actually was I would correspond back and
forth with her after that 2015 article
because her husband was struggling with
alcohol and so she was on the al-anon
side and she just wanted to understand
more about my experience and obviously
it was like I really want him to talk to
you but you know I would just kind of be
as you know like oh yeah have you tried
al-anon and you know just giving her any
suggestions that probably my sponsor
would have given to me or somebody else
you know and
but yes some other chefs have said yeah
I kind of struggle with alcohol and this
and that and I found your story really
inspiring so I think that you know it's
good also that it's out there because at
least you know people are it's
resonating with them and you know I
think that the more that sometimes we
talk about it at least the mental health
aspect of it it provides I don't know I
guess a resource because I definitely
felt like the way I was feeling in my
restaurant you know in the restaurant
industry with some of the woes of
management and just the hardship of you
know doing this thing that I'm really
passionate about but the constant you
know struggle with finances and
everything else that I was feeling alone
but then I went to the mad conference
which I'm sure Jeff has told you about I
know is something that Renee puts on in
Copenhagen
yeah yeah yes so when I went to that in
2016 a lot of it was about mental health
and I honestly coming back from that
felt really renewed that I you know cuz
just like in a a we get better as a
group and having people that we can
relate to so the same thing with that
being amongst my peers and able to hear
that they're struggling with the same
thing and we don't have to put up this
front that were like everything's okay
was extremely helpful because I was kind
of feeling at certain points like I was
pretty much going crazy you know and so
that helped me feel a lot better that
there was other people that were
experiencing the same thing yeah well
drinking just infuses the restaurant
culture in general right I mean it's
it's I mean I don't know what the
percentage of people that work in that
industry is
struggle with these kinds of things but
I would imagine it's probably high on
top of the fact that it attracts that
kind of personality
yeah I I'm so far being in the
restaurant industry I also feel like I'm
so far removed with what's actually
happening and maybe it's because like I
don't drink and I'm not in those circles
and so I don't know but I know that at
my restaurant a lot of my staff they
don't seem to be able to cut it if they
have problems with addiction and
alcoholism because it's funny how that
works but in the long run at least yeah
and and I think it's because we're so
small and we have to work so hard that
if you are too exceptionally tired on
too many days you just like can't do the
work that's that's required and so so I
find that in my environment I don't
think a lot of people struggle with
addiction or at least the staff that I
have or as far as I know because I don't
think that they have time for it but I
you know I don't know but I think that
there's definitely other restaurants
that maybe maybe they do and or maybe
they're just really good at hiding it
from me but yeah I think that it's
regardless of what I know about it I
mean I just know that the restaurant
industry at least when I was actively
using was definitely the place to be
right you know especially if you were
working in front of the house and making
good money like then you could go to the
bar and stay out till 4:00 and then wake
up at noon or 1:00 and go back to work
and it was easy to do yeah so you've
been you've been sober now almost 10
years yeah yeah yeah this December will
be 10 years
thanks but early on you bring your
version
alcoholism and your your budding gender
and sexual identity into the carnival of
the restaurant industry you're bouncing
around between all these restaurants
you're kind of learning your craft and
you know that's its own journey of
self-discovery so walk me up to getting
sober and what I'm really interested in
is when you start to to open up this
little business at the farmers market
that led to these dinners that you were
hosting in your apartment is I think
that that's sort of like the foundation
for what reasons yeah I was I so I spent
a lot of my 20s not only drinking but
also sober because I was in and out of
the program and I think those periods of
sobriety were very helpful to at least
get me one I mean I think if I had
continuously drank throughout my 20s I
probably would be dead now but so that
those moments helped me get some
perspective and help me get my [ __ ]
together at times and and I think it was
from that that I was able to have enough
of
I don't know mindfulness to be able to
think about like where I wanted my life
to go and so I made that decision to
move forward with the farmers markets
that was kind of like my my way to say
okay here's how I'm going to show people
that I know how to cook and that I can
do this and I can do this restaurant
business thing and I'll start by you
know just like showing people what I
want to do which is grow my own things
and make food from them make you know
prepared things like whether it's
tortillas or jams or biscuits or pasta
and then what I ended up making was
pierogi is I had a lot of beets that I
had grown
the garden and my yeah and I was like
alright I think I'm gonna mash these up
and put them in pierogies and then you
know she helped me figure out that dough
recipe by using the noodle recipe that
she would make with her grandfather and
or her uncle and so I went to the
farmers market with all these pierogies
and I was in the northwestern in eret
like in Crown Point that's the first
farmers market I did was in Indiana even
though I was living in Chicago and of
course being there like pierogi you know
people are very familiar with that
because they have the parolee fest and
everything else and there's still a
large Eastern European population there
so yeah I I had this huge line and sold
out immediately and figured okay this is
if this is what's gonna work even though
as I was making the pierogies I was
saying to myself I'm never gonna make
these again because of the labor
intensity of them I was like alright
this is what's gonna work and I think
that that probably one of my first kind
of ego beatdowns in the restaurant world
was like I'm never gonna make this
[ __ ] again and then was like well
this is what sells so okay I'm gonna
make this [ __ ]
so but people loved him and then somehow
I can't remember but somebody in Chicago
got word of that that's what I was
selling at the farmers markets and they
asked me to sell him in their store and
so then I had to come up with like a
little logo and packaging and then I
started selling him in in a grocery
store and then somehow the Chicago
magazine had gotten ahold of them in the
store and wrote about them and then so I
don't know if you remember this
publication but it was an online thing
called pop sugar and it really went to
the target market of you know pierogies
I guess
because they sent out a thing that said
that I you know it was something about
my parolees I don't remember but I just
got all these crazy amounts of orders
and then I started selling them at
another store and so then I was in a
couple of Chicago farmers markets and so
everybody thought I wanted to have a
pierogi restaurant which was not the
case but when I finally decided to do
the underground restaurant I had heard I
was so I was selling pierogies and
working as a server in a restaurant and
I had heard somebody talk about an
underground supper club and so I went
home and I googled that like what is
this and then I saw it was like people
who were having like dinner parties in
their homes you know and I thought well
are they were more so at like
undisclosed locations but I thought I
want to do that so I reached back out to
the press who had written about me and
my Probie since I'm gonna do this theme
are are you interested in writing about
it and they said yeah so I had a like a
soft opening for like doing an
underground restaurant in my house and I
invited the PopSugar people because I
knew that that had worked for the
pierogies and and a couple other people
and they came and they left and they
wrote about it and that filled me up for
a summer right you know and so then
after after that after I was booked for
the summer I quit my serving job and I
was still making the pierogies on the
side but then just doing the underground
full-time and through word-of-mouth like
I didn't have to go back to any other
job for at least two years and and
through so when people would come to the
dinners they would you know where I
would sit and talk to them at the end
and they would ask me you know like well
what's your goal with this and I said I
want to have a restaurant but at that
time some smaller restaurants had opened
like in Chicago like more of the
fine-dining boutique restaurants where
it wasn't like millions of dollars
poured into it or
their kitchens were just you know pretty
pretty small and it was really kind of
humble and there was this restaurant
called schwa which is still around and I
had worked with one of the guys at a
trio a long time ago and and I said you
know I kind of want to do something like
that you know cuz I know he opened with
less than like $80,000 and so I
eventually found some investors that
were like we can help you with this and
so yeah and that's that's how Elizabeth
came about it was you know yeah I like
in that I hear the story of somebody
who's slowly coming into their own and
learning how to trust their instincts
and their gut and finding their voice
right because somebody else could have
had that success with pierogies and turn
that into a big food company and there's
no restaurant or underground is like why
bother with that like I have this thing
here that people want like how do i
scale this and turn it into a huge thing
that's in every grocery store across
America I mean that could have been a
path that you could have pursued oh yeah
no that was that would have been
terrible and I a brother was like dad
there was mrs. T's Perot
yeah yeah and they used to sponsor
triathlon race and those things would be
at like every race oh I remember that
yeah well that but that's yeah I mean
that's the difference that's like why
I'm also like not a great business
person because most people would be like
oh that's that's the thing that you got
to do you know so you can make money
you're like no I'm gonna have dinners in
Grant Park like ten people right this is
the creative you know person that you
are right yeah you're following your
muse as opposed to what you know the
logical grounded rational person would
yeah and there were there were moments
throughout my restaurant career where it
was about like okay so the next thing
you do because you do want to eventually
make money right and it's like yeah okay
like I don't want to keep struggling
like this and so we opened
a bakery which you know just I didn't
have a great business partner and things
went south and also that was me trying
to run a second small business and do
all of the things which was just
impossible and then I was bunny
yeah and bunnies inside consumer well
that was the first version of bunny
which was its own separate thing and we
lasted for months and then there was
kitsune which came not long after that
and that was another attempt to like do
something I loved and a food that I was
really excited about and again the same
thing like I had plenty of great
investors on unscaled
any fault of theirs but we were
undercapitalized and I was trying to do
everything myself again and when I was
at one restaurant one would start to you
know lose their [ __ ] and vice-versa and
so I it just for two and a half years we
were just constantly struggling to pick
up the pieces even though we had a lot
of great reviews like you know Esquire
best new restaurants in GQ best new
restaurants in Chicago magazine best new
restaurants and there was all this great
press around it but still trying to you
know pay for things that you know were
already like way spent with just
spiraling in debt payroll like that the
veneer or the public perception versus
the yeah not so glamorous reality of
trying to run a business like that but
yeah I mean first of all you open up
concern a Japanese restaurant
you've never been to Japan like what's
what is going on there I think that our
focus you know I didn't even really
think about that like at the time like
it wasn't like that for me it was more
so like I was thinking about the
excitement that we had behind making our
own soy's
and cochise and working with ingredients
that were from Japan
that we things that we kind of did at
Elizabeth but really amplifying it so
taking the techniques and applying it to
everything that we had in from the
Midwest and really just honoring that
you know and not necessarily trying to
recreate anything that was like Japanese
but still using the methods if that
makes any sense so really just kind of
honoring it in that way but yeah I felt
like it was for me just exciting to be
pushing myself to study that and it
didn't really mean having to have been
there or lived there or anything like
that but I guess maybe from the outside
world people were like what an idiot
that's my chef's voice of other chefs
but it from my perspective it doesn't
seem like that's going on because what
the public perceived was here you have
Elizabeth this rest this beautiful
restaurant named after your sister who
passed away and you're opening up these
other restaurants and you're kind of
this queen of what's being dubbed the
new gatherer cuisine like you're at the
forefront like you're you're a face of
like this new vanguard of food that's
emerging and becoming more and more
popular so from the outside perspective
looking in it's like wow she's like this
crazy entrepreneur and this brilliant
creative chef and like all this good
stuff is happening so there had to be at
least in the Venn diagram or in the
timeline where everything seemed to be
working pretty good
yeah well probably yeah from from the
outside for sure but I think a lot of
you know people's direction was like you
you have to find something that becomes
something that's scalable and a little
bit more profitable
so that you can continue to support the
thing that's the creative one right
Elizabeth but what ended up happening
was that I think we also took kitsune to
be a little bit too cerebral as well you
know and it ended up becoming this like
honoring the Japanese cuisine and
techniques and people really didn't care
as much that we were like making our own
Koji's and our own mesos in this really
beautiful miso soup that we needed to
sell for $15 to like make it make sense
and I mean obviously there were the were
the people who cared right like you know
people who are having it that were
experienced in food whether it was you
know different critics or whatever but
then there was also like just from a
business standpoint like this is not
going to work like the labor and quality
and so I was actually not a good
business person in that way like I think
that that what I've learned with those
two ventures is that anything I do is
not really scalable because I care too
much like as we've already established
about like control and especially like
quality and things like that and so
where I've actually gone is to the
opposite side now where I'm almost
crawling back underground and we've even
more than underground have gotten this
like cabin which is in the middle of
nowhere you know it's a very it's like
if you if you look at it on Google Maps
your little blue dot is in the middle of
the Hiawatha National Forest like smack
I'm originally from Michigan I spent all
my summers growing up you know on Lake
Michigan my parents had a place on the
Leelanau Peninsula so I'm very familiar
with that part of the world and when you
were describing kitsune I know that one
of the sort of Achilles heels in that
restaurant was location right there's no
you know foot traffic in that
neighborhood et cetera so I'm thinking
well you have to you have it you have a
decision to make either you find
way to do what you're doing scalable or
you kind of pull a Rene Redzepi and you
close shop and you go on a walkabout and
you try to figure out what's most
important to you and you take your time
you breathe and milkweed this this this
thing that you've opened in the Upper
Peninsula is kind of your version of
Rene traveling the world in doing his
pop-ups like it's this new expression
that is truly not scalable and
incredibly difficult to get to but but
there's a beautiful story in that that I
think you know speaks to your ethos and
is very wedded in your childhood and why
you're even doing this to begin with
yeah I had I think I learned a lot of
that through the writing process and a
lot of it was me thinking about like
what am I gonna do like what you know
like really experiencing sometimes like
the desperation of like my my job is
cooking and this is what it is but how
am I gonna do this you know for another
10 years
at the level that I am in the restaurant
because it's quite exhausting and I
worry about you know my mental health
and and we want to have a family and how
do we find the time to actually do that
you know how do we find the time as two
women who have to work all the time to
actually you know have a family and be
able to like really do things that we
that are way more important in life then
you know working my ass off but and so I
think I'd spent the last like year and a
half or two years really thinking about
while writing the book like what do I
want my are our life to look like what I
want my life to look like
and how do we do that considering the
career that were in and so so yeah it's
definitely scaling down was one but like
how do we make that happen and how do I
get back to like just really making the
food make sense because I am thinking
about the whole time like one of the
most depressing things is actually you
know cooking this fancy food for people
that can afford it and or not they're
just really save up but like the the
carbon footprint of the deliveries and
we try to get all our things from
farmers and support them but like you
know even walking through the Whole
Foods and seeing the mounds and mounds
of just beautiful produce and you know
just thinking about just everything that
we do and trying to not waste it but
still the waste that's there and it's
just like doesn't feel right and I don't
know how you know when we look at other
restaurants that are trying to be green
who are serving you know a hundred
people a day like I struggle with just
serving 20 people a day in making sure
that I'm being conscious enough right
you know and the waste has to be
unbelievable yeah so how are other
people doing this and it just it's so
counterintuitive to actually how I want
to live or how I want to be in the world
and so doing something that's much
smaller but still doing what we do and
which is serving people in cooking for
them but also you know doing it this way
at milkweed just fits you know like
we're foraging for a lot of our stuff
but also you know our neighbor is he
comes over with these big lake trout
that he catches in Lake Superior and we
make those for people and go to the
farmers market once a week and support
the local farmers around there which
again is all things you can do in a
restaurant but it's just a way different
it's a way for me it feels so much
grounded its current you know it's it is
it is the gatherer cuisine like you
it's not not just in name but in
practice like your on you like 150 acres
yeah right and so you're foraging all
these mushrooms and these berries and
the like and gathering as much as that
of that food from literally the property
on which this restaurant sits which is
really an inn like people correct me if
I'm wrong but you can serve 10 people
they stay overnight they gotta get up
there and it's it's kind of like this
it's not just it's not just a dinner
this is an experience yeah and people
come on Fridays and we cook a little bit
of a more casual three-course dinner
than Saturday morning and make them
bread in toast and then we have a big
lunch that I cook over the fire and then
Saturday night there's a multi-course
dinner which is some more of the whimsy
more like you know planned out kind of
constructed storytelling dinner and then
Sunday morning there's a breakfast and
people have actually used it well they
want to obviously come to have all these
meals that I cook for them but they're
going hiking and they're going down to
the river and going swimming and trying
to go fishing I say trying because our
dog George always he's a Newfoundland
and he jumps in the river and so like
all the fish are gone and and so but
they're all they're using it they're
coming and then they're like oh next
we're going to this place so people are
using it as a spot to come to like
really as an inn as they go and take
their travels further along you know the
Great Lakes tour or the Upper Peninsula
and so it feels special to us and plus
like we get to connect with people who
are have been our guests for a long time
because some of the people that come to
Elizabeth came to my house you know and
they've still been with me through like
this whole entire journey and Mars yeah
it's pretty incredible considering them
like pretty introverted and like don't
have a lot to say but sometimes when I
get
then I really get talking but I feel
good job I feel comfortable with them
because they've started to just kind of
know that here's this shy person and I
just approach her and I don't you know
we just kind of enjoy each other's
presence you know and and they've gotten
to know me and it feels really special
and some people have become our very
close friends just even recently over
the years and but um and then we're
meeting new people too who have never
come to Elizabeth who have never done
anything with us but they lived in
Appleton or they live in Canada and they
heard about us and this is much closer
to get to than Chicago and it sounds
like a different experience so right now
there's two people who came to the cabin
who had never been to Elizabeth who are
from Chicago who are watching our dog
our Old English Sheepdog because they
fell in love with her at the cabin and
they were like we want to see her in
Chicago and so we're like well next time
we go out of town and so they're
actually watching her so yeah so it's
like this really awesome new experience
and way to connect with people which is
introverted as I am like I still love
people like I always say I hate them
because there's quite a lot about
humanity I don't know if it's called
humanity at that point but humans that I
don't really like but there's quite a
bit about humans in human nature that I
do love and that is one of those things
that I do is like really getting
together with people like that and
cooking for them and just kind of being
able to share myself with them through
cooking and us getting to know them and
so far it's been an incredible
experience yeah well one of the paths
forward to healing what ails us is
creating environments for people to get
together
and enjoy food in an intimate setting
and so I think that's important part of
you know bridging the gap or the you
know communication divide that seems to
have fractured us you know if we can get
across from a table and create a
communal experience um that seems like a
good way to begin to solve these
problems does not yeah I mean even
thinking about that on a very like a
more specific level like we've already
had people who are like you know from
well different cultures but even like
different political backgrounds and
they're all sitting at the table
together and I think everybody's smart
enough to not to bring up too much
politics but that they can actually all
sit together and have an amazing time
you know even our our neighbor we know
like we are in different definitely you
know places on that spectrum but we are
already connecting over food in love of
the outdoors you know and it's like yeah
we may have completely different like
political ideologies but we are still
human and we can still be friends and we
can still care about each other and you
know like coexist and and be happy well
there's got to be some characters up
there are they peninsula right probably
not a lot of married I think you're
probably saying you care about quickly
the well thought was we thought about
that and also yeah we are our neighbor
actually went to bat for us when some
people started to figure out what we
were doing up there because they were
very concerned about their hunting camps
and you know people coming through and
he reassured them that you know we were
good people and it was probably better
for us to have a B&B than another
hunting camp and you know people who
weren't you know also trying
to hunt the same animals that they were
and you know we were like no no your
studio be as a responsible caring
steward of the land yeah exactly and I
think that he explained that to them and
you know then the subject was changed
but and it was never brought up our
sexuality but I think that that was part
of something too that scared people a
little bit and they didn't know how they
should be approaching us but then he
settled everybody and we even had some
of those neighbors that were supposedly
mad at us come over and bring us some
welcome gifts and stuff like that so
yeah and I was also able to tell him to
tell them you know if we're gonna be
there a lot more than they are through
like the spring and summer months when
they're not out there hunting and we're
happy to go look at their cabins and
make sure that everything you know
nothing's collapsed under the snow or
you know whatever and so that yeah
exactly we get to be a little bit
stewards out there and watch other
people's places and help them take care
of it when they're not there how far
from the bridge is it from the Mackinac
Bridge yeah I don't know because we
don't come that way oh yeah no you come
up the other side on inose yeah two hour
two hours yeah yeah right Oh from that
side I know that from it's not easy to
get there no I know from with the
Wisconsin border once we cross over it's
about two and a half hours to get from
there to our place
and we're pretty much right in the
middle so it's probably yeah it's
probably similar from the other end as
well but um but you're closed now until
spring yeah and what you opened June
through August there's no we're actually
next year we're gonna be mid-may through
mid mid-october so full six months are
you taking reservations
for that yeah we're like uh half sold
out or you are well maybe a little bit
more than that I sent my dad my parents
live in Washington DC and I sent him the
Washington Post article about you and
milkweed and my dad was all about it I
was like I need to tell her so you can
look forward to my parents a hard case
you sellout yeah yeah it's been it's
been awesome we've even had people who
live in the Upper Peninsula come and
actually say like well this is an an
incredible spot because even some of
their areas like don't you have to when
you're driving up you do go
the elevation becomes a little bit
higher but it's extremely gradual and
once you get to our place we're on the
top of like a tiny mountain but when
you're looking out you can see like that
we're pretty much up there and it's just
a beautiful landscape because we're
right butted up to the we're in the
Hiawatha but there's also some private
areas that are being developed by
loggers but then when you get to our
property it's butted up against the
Hiawatha we're actually nobody's going
to be logging in so there's just so much
so like it's just covered in trees yeah
that's awesome I can't help but kind of
reflect your career against the
trajectory of what Renee is doing with
Noma and I don't if you know this but
yeah I joined Jeff this past summer and
went to know man have been there yeah
yeah have you for you obviously you know
Renee gave you a blurb for your books
yes the other certain you know the most
renowned kind of foraging oriented show
right yeah we um I've had dinner there
twice because I've been too mad twice
sorry
2014 2016 and then Anna and I went there
for Noma Mexico so we went down to Tulum
and I stashed for a day in the
and and then we had dinner and and yeah
it's it's incredible that was the Tulum
Mexico no my experience was probably one
of my best meals every chef was there
for that too like this yeah we we had
just missed each other but yeah I know
he went down there for that too so I did
kind of in preparation for going there I
did a little bit of a deep dive on this
whole kind of foraging culture and
learned what I thought so I thought I
kind of knew what was going on when I
arrived did when you went to Noma was it
the current incarnation of that no it
was still in their old location so I
haven't been to any of the new menus
it's it's pretty crazy like I knew it
was gonna be this extraordinary
restaurant but what I didn't anticipate
was that he's literally it's almost like
a mini University like it's a compound
with like several test kitchens and like
multiple buildings and there had to be
30 or 40 young people working in the
kitchen to serve like less than that I
don't know 40 or something like that and
I got to meet David Zilber his
fermentation guy and get to know him a
little bit and and I walked away from
that experience realizing like I didn't
know anything about what it is that he
does but a couple things that I noticed
is he's really learned how to create a
culture and and cultivate a team because
he's the executive chef like he's not in
there preparing the meals like he's the
he's the conductor of this amazing
Orchestra but he's running like this
massive operation in contrast I see you
know I think that potential you know
reality exists for you as well and to
see you kind of go in a different
direction after you know having had a
similar kind of reboot experience that
he had to go small and keep it intimate
yeah that's so everything they do then
yeah pretty much reduce it down to one
and honor definitely helping me because
we were out foraging this summer and
just you know with the amount of time it
takes to collect what we collect to even
just serve to people and to prepare it
and clean it and save it and make sure
everything's good is like wow when I
think about how they do it like that's
why they need so many people you know
and because if you want to really serve
that kind of thing and be stewards of
the land in a way but then also like I
don't know how they do it for you know
forty people at lunch or if they have to
services like I'm I'm absolutely still
baffled even with that many people in
the kitchen it's really incredible it's
an incredible feat because but yeah I
mean I've I've thought about it and I
think it's different when you have like
the the status that he has and the
ability to have the teams that he's
constructed and I know that they've had
their moments was struggling financially
and and every restaurant does no matter
if you're the best restaurant in the
world or you know nowhere on any of
those Maps but you know that I feel like
there's a lot of resources there which I
don't know if I could ever get but now
that I know that I would never want
because even with kitsune when I was
making the decisions to close that I
felt like I had to try every single
thing possible first before I could go
back to our investors and say I can't do
this and you know it was to the point of
madness because I was losing their money
and for a lot of them they were probably
investing amounts that they knew that
they could afford to lose but for me it
was something different and I was really
just thinking about them because I
didn't care how that reflected on my ego
like I am so happy that restaurants gone
you know and I didn't care if it looked
like I had failed because I really
didn't feel like I
did it didn't feel like a failure it
felt like a really part of like just an
economic situation that was not only
like in our climate but also who I was
as a person you know not willing to make
sacrifices to shop at Cisco or you know
companies where I couldn't look at the
product and think this is exceptional so
but yeah they have a whole different
I really admire him and his life the way
that they think about food and you know
everything because I felt really
connected to that restaurant when I
first heard about them in 2010 or 2011
so well after they were already
established and after they were
established with you know being a
foraging restaurant rather than what
they were before and I obviously felt
really connected to that because that
was the same place that I was coming
from with my cooking because when I
started I was like oh I'm gonna go with
what I know you know which is being very
local I'm very seasonal and foraging and
all of that and so have always really
really admired them and I think that
there's not a single thing you know you
there's Renee if you see his food you
know you'll have seen like probably a
hundred other chefs somehow you know
been inspired by it in one way or one
diaspora yeah and you know and even he
will say like well you know and his food
comes from somewhere else that it was
inspired by you know or yeah and they do
do a lot of things that I think I I
don't know who else is you know making
egg yolk mold pies so that might be
something brand new to them I don't were
you having the mold well they made sure
that that I went for the plant kingdom
menu
they they like went out of their way to
make sure I mean it was essentially 95%
vegan now it is but they went to extra
percent to make sure that everything
that I had was totally right yeah it's
amazing of itself but yeah I had the
multi the vegan version of that and like
everything I mean it was it was crazy I
mean I thought like oh this will be an
amazing experience and I just couldn't
believe like what I was eating like it
was just so different than anything I
could have imagined or anticipate yeah
yeah I'm right I'm really interested in
in that because I had heard one of my my
chefs was telling me about a chef she
worked for in Chile and they were trying
to inoculate vegetables so that it kind
of grew like that cheese almost
camembert mold on it and then I I don't
know if they accomplished it or what but
I was like wow like that's crazy and I
started to think like on a on a
scientific level how that would work and
then I saw that Noma was like figuring
this out and I don't know how how they
do it but I just kept thinking like wow
I really want to see what that tastes
like because that's you know I think
that that's the curiosity and the thing
that is what they're doing that's so
magical is that you know they're really
reverting to you know nothing that's new
you know making Koji's and making miso
sand fermenting and all this stuff that
has been around forever but then
creating new flavors out of that and you
know so that
well it's Zilber i mean that guy is on
the edge of that world and he has
I mean you studied chemistry he's got an
entire lab yeah devoted to trying to
figure this stuff out and we did a tour
I have it like as a highlight on my
Instagram stories you could check like
Maria gave us a whole tour before dinner
but we go through the fermentation lab
and go into there the walk-in
refrigerator and there's this giant you
know gigantic mason jars with different
fermentations of everything you can
possibly imagine
there we're just testing everything
trying to come up with new flavors that
have never been discovered yeah yeah I
don't have a fermentation lab but I have
a couple I don't think anybody else does
cabinets but this goes back to you know
what you learned with your mom and yeah
and usually Lanning since you were a kid
yeah it's sometimes ours is like I don't
know I grew this weird thing it doesn't
look like it's bad okay let's pinch off
a little piece and yeah I don't know how
they figure out like what's safe and
what's you're not gonna kill you mmm-hmm
yeah well I think it you know they I've
heard that if it's not like black mold
and if it's not green and if it's not
fuzzy then it should be okay right like
ever there was one thing they served
what was it it was a maybe it was the
mold pie like it was something that if I
had opened up my refrigerator and saw it
in the pantry I would throw it out
others like yeah yeah but I don't know
there there's it's just incredible and
his food is so beautiful and and you
know it's really inspiring and so yeah I
think a lot of people are you know it
just extremely attracted to that in a
lot of chefs you know it's yeah it's
incredible to see what they do and the
way that he pushes the food movement and
I think I mean ten years ago like people
were talking about fermentation for sure
but not on the level that they are now
and even like the same people like if
we're just using Instagram or Twitter as
a source like the same people that I
would see you know that I've been
following for a couple years now are
like I did this koji thing and this mold
thing and this other thing you know and
so everybody does really kind of he I
think that he's the one who is like okay
we're gonna do this next and then you
know slowly yeah
everybody else is doing it these trends
I mean you know let's just check our
privilege like you know very few people
get to have the opportunity of going to
a place like Noma or the ability to go
to the Upper Peninsula and experience
what you're creating right these are
very privileged experiences but they are
touchstones culturally that that then
you know sort of find their way into the
you know the mainstream discussion and
dialogue and practices of quizzes well
yeah I think chef Jeff was talking about
a young lady who is in I want to say at
Austin Texas but I'm not sure who is
doing a lot of that and he was talking
about her on the Dave King podcast I
can't remember her name right now but
you know it's now all of these kind of
things but it's coming in a paper boat
you know like just like talking about I
think he talked about that yeah I can't
remember the name of that restaurant
though that's true
oh yeah yeah yeah you know I think you
wrote about her as well might be
Nashville I can't remember what it is
yeah I can't remember I somewhere in the
southeast over but anyway yeah I mean I
think that that's that's interesting
yeah so it does it does eventually yeah
translate in into a little bit for
everybody but I I don't know I think
that yeah it's interesting
oftentimes I find myself you know when I
get really excited about a lot of these
different projects one wanting to teach
myself it and it's like well will I use
it or not I don't know it just depends
if I can apply it but of course I want
to learn which you know keeps me sharp
as a chef which i think is and and Jeff
talked about this in his book to like
the curiosity of ranae you know and I
feel like I have that same curiosity and
and I did as a child too which I think
made sense like you know growing up
around things that we were collecting
and then everything be it became like
what can I eat this and can I eat this
and you know so that implanted that into
me that the curiosity but you know it
drives me to want to learn how to do
but then I find that I want to check
myself too and be like do all right is
this necessary do I need to put this in
the food does everything need to be like
on the plate dry-aged koji fermented and
also me sewed and also salt fermented
like does every you know I don't think
like there's becomes a place where it's
like okay we have part of that is ego
versus what's actually service yeah does
it even make sense yeah so you know it's
like cool and it's fun but then where
does where do I have to draw the line
and there became a point to where like a
year ago I said to my chef okay like
let's do a menu where we don't sir we
only serve things actually on plates and
in bowls and like remove the twigs in
the moss in the rocks in the shells you
know and like just make sure
everything's on a plate so yeah go
through those moments too because yeah
it's very easy to get caught up and
seeing beautiful things and then being
like I want to you know serve something
on a rock and serve something on some
moss and just like when does that
actually make sense and when doesn't it
you know like and now being at milkweed
it almost makes zero sense
at my restaurant to serve things on Moss
but at milkweed it makes complete sense
to serve things on Moss even though we
haven't served too much unless right
well its remaining it's it's it's trying
to root yourself in that childlike state
and staying there right there's purity
that and and there is this full circle
thing about you kind of you know you you
know there's a there's a part in the
book where you lament the loss of the
farmhouse and what that meant to you and
and and that was more kind of impactful
on you than even your parents you know
the strife in your parents marriage but
now it's this like kind of coming home
like ruining yourself and what got you
into this to begin with and it seems
like that provides this beautiful kind
of robust tableau for you to really in a
tactile way like connect with that
childlike state that allows you to
create on that level though yeah there
was a couple years ago where I was just
feeling really depressed all the time
and what I would think about at night
when I was laying in bed was how badly I
wanted to feel like a kid again like how
badly I wanted to go back to that
feeling like the child that I used to
feel like and I think that was a big
part of you know writing my book too
when I was writing that early childhood
section I was remembering just kind of
like the innocence and you know just how
comforted I felt in that house and so to
feel better I would tell myself at night
like I'm gonna buy that house back
someday I'm gonna get that house back
and I thought that that was gonna like
cure me being able to go back there and
create a life there but um instead it
became like how can I just create that
atmosphere anyways you know how can I
get back there in the way that I need to
now in obviously in a way that makes
sense and I think that that's how
milkweed
like you know came was a lot of that
like really thinking like how do I want
to feel and where do I want to go from
here you know so that was a big part of
it because then like a year or so later
I think well maybe like six months later
I met Anna and then about a year or so
later that's when I started looking like
at cabins and things like that and in
off the grid and like wow where where
could we actually go and then start it
sort of obsessing about it
well healthier emotionally than trying
to buy the old farmhouse in yeah but
yeah I think it so you know like a big
part of what I've done or what I do is
you know like really say like okay this
is what I'm going to do and then do it
like figure
out how I can do the things which a lot
to a lot of people might seem like
nonsense at the time even when we got
we're getting close to actually opening
this summer for milkweed I had a couple
like realizations where I would be like
oh my god this is [ __ ] crazy like
what are we doing but it's like well I
guess we're doing it like let's find the
most remote hardest place to get to in
America and open a restaurant there for
10 people yeah and I didn't even go
there first right like I bought it
without actually having visited the
location yeah and then the first time I
drove there I couldn't even get through
which was in early April and then was
there any structure on the property oh
yeah yeah yeah like the whole the whole
place was there like there was it was
just we hadn't seen it in person so yeah
like yeah and it was really complicated
to get to and so after I finally got
there I came home and told on I was like
I don't know how we're gonna get people
back there but we're gonna figure it out
somehow so well I think it's working
people are interested in it and looking
back it's one of those things where it
appears that all that all the dominoes
are perfectly lined up to bring you to
this place yeah does it like how does
that color how you think about destiny
and fate does it feel like this is your
destiny that you were fated to do this
or yeah I I think that you know that
there's still like a lot to come because
you know I we will figure this out and
see how it works for us and and work out
the kinks and you know maybe we realized
that the in 2021 we don't want to do it
for six months out of the year maybe you
know we talked a lot about maybe being
able to be what are they called winter
birds or summer Birds like we're already
snowbirds we're already planning our
yeah so like we go to milkweed when it's
warm during the summer months and then
maybe we find someplace in like New
Mexico that's like an old you know route
66 motel that has ten rooms and then we
create an in there as well and we go
there during the winter and I don't know
we got a bunch of ideas she would like
to maybe raise a family out in this area
and I was like I don't know what I'm
gonna do for work because I'm definitely
not moving to LA and opening a
restaurant no so I I don't know I feel
like we're still really young in that
way and and thinking about like well
what do we do when we grow up you know
maybe don't grow up it's the childlike
nature in here that allows you to do
what you do yeah yeah so I don't know I
don't know what but right now at least
it feels good and I actually feel
refreshed being back at Elizabeth's and
we've kind of even scaled that back a
little bit and I have somebody in the
office now doing a lot of my office were
again so we've restructured in a way
that feels good you've hired a chef when
you were right but are you gonna be back
oh yeah no now he's he he was done at
the end of August and now I've been back
in the kitchen managing and actually
full-time which so instead of having a
kitchen boss I have a boss in the office
which allows me to be the boss back in
the kitchen and so I feel like we're
always evolving in that kind of way but
I feel I've I feel good about it I
probably have had a lot less complaints
lately about my job and being back in
the kitchen than I did a year ago you
know before I was like I'm never going
back there you stay away from the
dishwasher no I still been washing the
dishes
this is a lesson I think we need but
yeah it's been feeling feeling good I
feel a little bit more rejuvenated so
well good let's land this plane I mean I
think the final thing that I think would
be kind of cool to leave people with is
what like what is it that you want maybe
you haven't even thought about this but
like what is it that you would like
people to take away from your story and
this book I I have thought about it um
because I've gotten that question you
know like who is this book for and I
think it's for everybody and I think
what people can take away from it is
that like no matter what circumstance
you're in or if there's something out
there you think that you want to do but
think you can't do like you have to
erase that because that was still a
guiding principle for me as like that
friend that I mentioned in the book that
always said like what are you waiting
for permission and it's like you don't
need it just like whatever you want to
do like do it set the intention and then
take all the steps for it and even if
you're told know along the way like keep
trying because all my first books that I
wrote were rejected every time I talked
about the restaurant I wanted to have
somebody told me no that I couldn't do
it and Here I am having a restaurant
having that property in the middle of
nowhere which people told me was never
gonna happen and also having a book that
was published so right you know and the
book was many years right like you the
the the editor or the publisher that
published it initially reached out to
you but then you kind of danced with a
major publisher for a while and
ultimately went back right like there
was many years you approached me in 2015
I wrote for about a year then I escaped
for about a year and and worked with a
agent in that fell flat on its nose and
then I went back to him so yeah it's a
story of her
fairness and individuality and survival
and identity it's really quite an
accomplishment it's a beautiful book I
highly suggest everybody pick up on the
place in the meantime maybe read The New
Yorker article about the book which is
that's like super cool to talk about who
gets who gets their book written about
in The New Yorker like that's amazing
yeah pretty much just famous people and
then me
they called it brutal and luminous yes
all these like really cool adjectives
yeah yeah a lot of people like to use
the term gothic around it too so I think
it has a lot of that you know there's
aspects of it that reminded me of just
kids Patti Smith's book I mean it's a
very different story
yeah you would love that book but
there's something very like the
singularity of the voice because your
voice is so unique and hers is as well
and like just leaning into that as
opposed to trying to you know adapt to
some convention right yeah well I'm glad
that I went back to my small publisher
because the agent was actually gonna
have me ghost written by somebody and
also disaster yeah so it would not have
you know and also insisted that I write
the book of lunar Lynn I can't even say
yeah well I'm glad you wrote it the way
that you wrote it yeah it's a huge
accomplishment and well done and you
seem happy yeah so best of luck to you
thank you and come back and talk to me
again sometime okay and I want to come
to your restaurant yeah and and also
with your parents to Mowgli
yeah we'll be in touch on that cool so
for everybody listening out there what's
the best way to connect with you Oh best
way is probably through Instagram or
Twitter so I think our Instagram is
Elizabeth restaurant underscore and
underscore CO and then Twitter is at
Elizabeth rest
uh-huh you have a personal Twitter but
you have an update
it seems like 2013 yeah it's I don't use
them yeah cool and pick up burned the
place you won't regret it
thank you alright peace foraging
mushrooms
[Music]